وقع امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني في القصر الرئاسي في بشكيكه عاصمه
قرنستان على عدد من الاتفاقيات ومذكرات
التفاهم بين بلدين وكان امير قطر وصل الى
قرغيزيستان في زياره ضمن جوله خارجيه وكان
في استقباله الرئيس صادر جبروف وعدد من
المسؤولين
معنا من القصه الرئاسي في بشكيك كمراسل
الجزيره احمد الجاسم احمد مرحبا بك معنا
اذا ابرز ما تم التوقيع عليه من اتفاقيات
في هذه الزياره
نعم محمد انتهت مراسم استقبال امير دوله
قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني في القصر
الرئاسي هنا في بشكيك وكان في استقباله
رئيس جمهوريه قرقية صادر جباروف وعددا من
المسؤولين او الوزراء ثم توجه امير قطر
الى قاعه الاستقبال الرسميه وقائد التوقيع
الاتفاقيات حيث وقعت عددا من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم ابرزها اتفاقيه
نقاشيه حول فتح الحدود بين قطر
وقرقيزيا حدود مباشره او طيران مباشر بين
قطر وقار او بشكيك سفير جمهوريه قرقي ايضا
لدى الدوحه صرح بمثانه علاقات البلدين
وحرصهما على تطويرها في مختلف المجالات
واشار ايضا الى ان بلاده تبذل جهودا
لزياده وتوسيع القاعده الاقتصاديه لبدء
مشاريع جديده في مجال كالطاقه والصناعه
والتعدين والامن الغذائي التكنولوجيا
المعلومات ايضا اخذت حيزا كما دعى ايضا
رجال الاعمال القطريين
السفير الى استكشاف الفرص المتاحه في
قرقيزيا مؤكدا ان هناك نحو 50,000 فرصه
استثماريه جاهزه في الوقت الراهن بما في
ذلك مشاريع بتملك مئه في المئه والشراكه
بين القطاعين الخاص والعام يقول مسؤلون
هنا في قرقيزيا
ان هناك مسار ايجابي بين كلا البلدين
للتبادل التجاري والتعاون الاستثماري
خصوصا ان اقتصاد قرقيزيا يدخل مرحله
التعافي بعد انكماشه العام الماضي
وكذلك المؤشرات ايضا تشير الى ان الاقتصاد
القطري يشهد نموا سريعا بحد تعبيرهم
محللون ايضا اقتصاديون قالوا ان فرص
الاستثمار المتبادل بين دوله قطر وجمهوريه
غاردينيا خصوصا باتحاد القطاع الخاص
بين القطاعيه الخاص بين قطر
وقرغيزيا مع وجود تسهيلات تجاريه ايضا
بامكانه ان يسهل العديد من الاتفاقيات
خصوصا ان دوله قطر تم لك من الدوحه ومطار
حمد الدولي ايضا يعتبرون من اكبر البوابات
التجاريه بين كلا البلدين شكرا لك احمد
الجاسم مراسل الجزيره من بشكيه